we got a voicemail at two one nine to  david p from furious drunk from pused  jimmy from philly and he is saying he is  not going to apologize for trolling me  here's what he had to say  David Jimmy from Zoe I just wanted to  say that you know I've been drinking a  lot lately and leaving naughty  voicemails and you know naughty comments  on YouTube so much you had to shadow  damn me but uh I'm never apologizing  you're you kidding me  yeah Jimmy from Philly thanks very much  for letting us know he is not going to  be apologizing for the trolling and I  think that that is not a huge surprise  to anybody who's heard his voicemails  before we've got a great bonus show for  you today become a member at WWE at  muncom become a patron both give you  instant access to the bonus show and I  will speak to you there in just a minute  or two